speaking of enemies of the
show here is the omelet of
knowledge he's not really an enemy I'm
being I'm being dramatic with these guys
ABA and
preach
um apparently in Quebec he's like a
local
celebrity and he does standup comedy and
apparently people like come to his shows
and
stuff yeah yeah what does he talk about
the like
break the
eggs it's like get on where's the joke
brother wow you a [__] okay come on go
easy on him go easy on preach we kid him
we kid him cuz we love him he made a
comment about your
boobies they got a lot of sound they got
a lot of sound I'm not going to lie like
they pulling out course I didn't even
know you made they talking about your
movies what is that from I don't even
know we're not their enemy the enemies
of their podcast anymore cuz you
remember before you used to get mad when
he saw her name I [__] hate these
guys but but not mad enough to to to
watch the whole videos no they they
haven't they don't bother me enough yet
but I'll tell you
this I'm [__] insane they're pathetic
they're Liars they're dishonest and
they're phonies they're I guess they're
better than fresh and fit and stuff for
sure like
well and then they make a video saying
how like she's a liar and [__] I
don't I didn't watch it to be I watched
I watched some of it but
watch it he just mad enough to make
assumption about what we're doing and
make assumption about what we saying
without watching videos I think what
happened was he found out the homie that
was gessing him Assan is actually like a
giant piece of [__] that was sending
people and his community after his wife
and him and then he said you know what
these guys were right
about cuz they they cut the podcast you
know they stop doing the podcast of
course of course because of the because
because he's Jewish right oh and his and
H's Community was like that must man
wasn't so bad they was Wilding on him
his wife they had cartoons of his wife
just mowing down Palestinians like they
was posing crazy [__] Ethan was breaking
down crying and his s was just like I
don't give a [__] and I sitting in the
back like you thought we was the piece
of [__] a Michael Jackson song and we we
uh ran AI through it so it's just his
voice so we could play it for you guys
uh well so there wasn't a claim on the
original I say we should watch the
original oh no claim yeah okay fantastic
if you want to play both I think we
should watch the original and then and
then let's hear just his vocals we
should do his vocals and then just
squeak squeaky floor in the background
here if you need
something for your
soundboard there happy big I love that
people always make fun of this
floorboard but oddly enough YouTube is
all about being authentic and kind of
simple in that way and this is the
apartment we started filming in this is
where we pretty much started everything
but a lot of people Tred to use it
against I'm I don't mind like to me I'm
like proud of the roots in a weird way
it's crazy
cuz thanks floor complimented me you
wouldn't understand yeah did you you
really I really see it when they try to
use it hey what your cookie ass floor we
change your FL and you broke
[__] the reason why we even
started here was because we couldn't
afford to have a whole setup and so I
had to run it out of my own place just
to be able to cut down C so we can make
videos for a long time cuz we didn't
make any money at all let's see what our
boys got I'm going to be I'm going to be
open-minded yeah anyone from Quebec have
any details about his local celeb I'm
curious yeah I tried to find what the
show was called but uh I was not
successful but you guys are uh angones
and you only speak English so you want
to know what that means it means live
from the universe basically it's funny
too because people will meme on you
sometimes and like they'll say oh preach
is not like articulate or not bright or
they'll say like om knowledge or
whatever it's my third [__] language
that's what that's why I think
realize my third language I just think
it's funny that people who are
unilingual speak only one language can't
spot the fact that someone else doesn't
have an issue with knowledge per se but
what they actually have an issue with is
maybe just English and getting every
thought across because you see him in
interviews in French you notice a
difference but the thing that happened
is that they don't even understand that
whenever I'm talking like that there's a
there has to be a process in my mind
like I have to literally translate
everything that happens in my head and
then in a split seconds to send it to
you so sometimes I'm I'm more intricate
stuff on on top of the fact that when I
was a kid I had a big huge speech
impediment that happened when I was like
stress whatever whatnot you know I used
to study and Mumble and stuff like that
so just that you know people are
clowning this and that yeah I don't like
how's your
French how's your French it's weird
because I got
two two two different things two
different things going on the the the
more internet stuff and the English
stuff and I got the the more local
Quebec stuff and so I I I don't care
about the fact that yeah this dude's
like a celebrity out here like I'll be
walking around taking the subway and
I'll just see him on billboards people
send me links all the time of him doing
some new TV pilot for like French
television and stuff like that so people
don't recognize on YouTube it's one
thing but he has a completely different
life and it's just interesting to me
whenever people talk about his career
like oh all he does is in this room or
maybe he stutters a bit I'm like you
guys have no idea not figure it out he
flaring up right now all right so he was
talking about my Tourette yeah yeah
stupid he's kind a fair game you know
anyway go ahead
[Music]
omelette okay is this a singing
show we cannot find any
context so we can't find anything about
it but there's a whole ass room of
people there's a whole TV crew this is
what happens when Americans realize that
America is not the whole
world yeah you can't find any about it
cuz they're not advert advertising to
you cuz you don't speak their language
there's no reason for you to know about
there's
people well you can see the you can see
the network here it says dude he's he's
kind of he's throwing himself into it
that's what teing it up he's throwing
himself fully into it I appreciate the
enthusiasm you can you can see the
network name here it's C Telly t e l e
with the the accent over the e
Z that was pretty good accent that was
hey is it Z Yeah Boy it is hey you can
clip that put it in your soundboard is
it
[Music]
yeah not going lie this is the most
Wonderbread version of Michael Jackson
this one it's white or it's white but it
is but it is white yeah your backup
singers yeah yeah they don't have an
ounce of Soul there there is there's no
flavor this is tuna casserole you
[Music]
think he really has it all he's the song
He's the song The Dance and the
philosophy I don't hate this yeah I I I
can't I can't hate this he's not I can't
really hate on it either he's not he's
not a fantastic singer he's okay
throwing himself into it plus his fit is
I I dig his fit I got to give him
that he's doing the dance from the music
video I'll say this I like that he threw
himself I respect that let's continue
but I was going to say did we call them
red pilled I don't know someone yeah you
did yeah but I'll say that probably you
at some point I think you may have yeah
they're not red pilled I like that
they're in touch with um with their
artistic side
he saw you dancing I'm like that not red
p i mean anyone who knows us we we've
been dancing singing from the start no
that's what happens when you react to
stuff that you didn't even watch yes
that's what happens but karma you know
what I mean but
karma so I respect that about
[Music]
him oh my
God I had
to yeah you didn't but you did I had
to you're gonna do it might as well do
it right I might as well just make a
turn that kick was solid kick grab my
but you didn't do the hip thrust no I
didn't which I think is what was missing
I know plus but if you going to do MJ
you got to do the hip thrust or you got
to do the circles the circles like you
know when he grabs it and he's like this
he goes he's jumping around but I
grabbed it and I went down down
they didn't see it my bad my bad I'm I'm
sorry I didn't see it either that's my
fault that's my fault I don't know why I
doubted you cuz you would have done it
properly if you I went I went turn kick
and then bam bam oh no that's shoulders
that's not hips yeah but don't make me
stare make sure you did it properly n no
that's weird n that's weird I hear yeah
let you see them hips move that's crazy
I never said
that you said you did it but I you you
have to do it again I no no no no I just
said I just did that [__] listen I know
you didn't do it cuz I watch but I'm
angry that he made me watch I didn't
make you watch you wanted to watch none
of you could see it because you guys are
not sub to our patreon if you want to
see preach hip thrust you can sign up
for exclusive content it's not going to
be there check out the patreon over
hundreds of exclusive videos up there
right now now let's listen to the one
without backing music though just
because we're douches and we and we like
to do them like that fair warning the
because the audio quality of this video
is not great I mean it's not it's not
that terrific yeah okay it's it's decent
though you'll see but I'll say this uh
as a as a body of of people we sending
peace and love to Omelette what say
they're sending peace and love to to
Palestine cool you just have to go
straight
to what the
[Applause]
[__]
[Music]
[Applause]
AI is crap you want to just give him a
rendition no come on let the people let
our fans know you know when I said dark
child that when you know a song is going
to be fine when it starts you did the
[Music]
notes yeah I know you can bu him up how
do you bu I don't even remember uh the
the song to be honest with you the
lyrics yeah of all the Michael Jackson
songs it's not the one that I would it's
black or it's white is kind of weird to
me it it screams like you have a white
wife I do yeah so I feel like you should
have
this all right now this part is turning
into a fever dream and it's making me
uncomfortable it's so funny every time
he does the little little dance with his
feet they cut away from his feet for
some reason where they don't want to
show it they just don't understand he's
just his sneaker game is crazy probably
they don't want everyone at home to be
feel stunted on we too
distracting but okay we we give it up we
honor omelette somebody said he's no
Enrique and glaus in a good way that's a
compliment right yeah he's better you're
better than Enrique
[Music]
glacius now play that with his omelette
the omelet of knowledge together and the
squeaks give me give me one second to do
that I gonna have to juggle some [__]
around here cut away seems like uh Ethan
Klein has regretted some of the words he
said growth is okay that's it and as far
as I'm concerned you know him him him
throwing shots I don't I don't even mind
it if you want to just crack jokes about
people call them silly call them a
little stunted go crazy go crazy all
right so I'm not even butur I know a lot
of folks sent me this can you believe
what whatever he didn't say he didn't
say anything you make fun of some things
who cares we make fun of things all the
time it's okay it's okay
so that's what I think about it I'm I'm
not uh I'm not going to get upset cuz
they're insulting preach no it's fine
it's it's
fine now if it was me [__] we got a
problem you can't be talking about me no
omelet bro you call me no bro would you
have done nothing yeah of course not huh
what you want but I would have been
upset cuz I'm sensitive you're not
sensitive but we're not going to go over
that [__] anything else you want to say
omelette no come omel let
[Laughter]
again what are you going to do what are
you going to do what are you going to do
shut that camera off yeah what you going
to do what you going to do yeah
yeah